We are addressing the fungal kingdom
and exploring.
It has profound impacts on
global human health,
on agriculture and food security,
and on biodiversity.
So the sorts of questions
we'd like to get
at is it's very clear
that fungi are the cause
of devastating threats to food security worldwide,
to human health.
They're killing over 1.5 million people every
year which is more than malaria and they're
also causing extinctions in real-time of amphibians
for example and bats.
And so their impact is clear, but we know
very little about where these pathogens have
originated, how they evolved, these traits
that allow them to cause such devastating
impact, how they've evolved resistance to
the therapeutics and the agricultural fungicides
that we use to try to control them.
So we brought together a consortium
of individuals
who work on plant fungal pathogens,
and the
risk to agriculture and food security,
individuals
who work on fungal pathogens
that are decimating
animal populations globally,
and then investigators
working on human fungal pathogens both physician
scientists, basic scientists, and bio informatics
genomics experts who are helping reveal key
features and vulnerabilities of these organisms
that we can exploit for new treatments.
So I think the most attractive and enabling
aspect of the CIFAR model for us is that it
allows us to bring together an extraordinarily
inter-disciplinary team.
So we have assembled leading experts in really
diverse areas that are in sort of traditionally
disparate disciplines and so we're able to
bring them together under this sort of unique
program to tackle these global grand challenges
that couldn't be accomplished in any other
means, and we're going to explore sort of
where they came from, how they've evolved
these traits and leveraged that kind of insights
to develop really new strategies to thwart
these fungal pathogens.
[Music]